Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning podcast and just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you. Um,
I have no life. I don't know what to talk about. I've got no fucking life, man.
We're just right in this God damn show, having a great time doing it, of course.
But, uh,
I just stay in a writers room and I stare at a computer screen all day long and
my eyes were killing me yesterday. It, uh,
I started looking around the room and I noticed,
I think I'm the only one in the room that doesn't wear glasses.
That's like, uh,
that's like earning your stripes as a writer is you actually,
you wear glasses that, and you can do that thing where you, you know,
you spin the fucking pen around your finger and you can catch it. You know,
those, you know, friend of mine always said mathletes could always do that,
you know, but, um, anyways,
I'm going to do some standup this weekend. Um, we just, uh,
we just did the table read for episode two. Uh,
Dave Kepner came in and just crushed it as Bob Pogo was fucking awesome. And,
uh, you know, that's probably my most favorite thing about the week, uh,
is doing the table reads cause it's,
it feels like doing stand up in front of the La live like crowd for those of you
not in the business. It's basically after you write the thing,
you sit down and before you record it, you basically,
you do it in front of a bunch of people who've invested in the show.
So they're hoping it's funny, but if it isn't funny, they're not going to laugh.
So if they, if you get them laughing,
if you get industry industry people laugh and that's always a big thing.
So we had a great table read some very excited about that. Um,
and um, anyways, but that's not what I want to talk about here today.
I gotta tell you something I found the other day, uh, when I was on youtube, um,
any wrestling fans out there, ah,
anybody old like me used to watch fucking Tony, Gloria and Larry's a Bisco.
Ivan put ski and Bulldog Brower and Pat Patterson. And Ted Dibiase,
the Internet intercontinental champion.
You know dusty Rhodes?
Yeah.
Mr Fuji. Mr ITTO, the moon dogs.
Okay.
George the animal Steele. Super stabbed. Billy Graham.
Bob backlit. Bruno Sammartino.
Okay.
Greg to Hammer Valentine and can't remember how many these fucking guys who
still remember Tony Atlas. Jimmy superfly snooker.
I still remember that finishing moves.
Tony Atlas would just fucking basically do a military press with you.
He'd just pick you up over his head and he fucking throw you right Andre.
The giant would just put his giant fucking size 48 foot.
You throw you off the ropes and just stick it right in your face and he'd sit on
you. I haven't put ski. Had the Polish Hammer.
Greg Valentine had the figure four leg lock.
That's the time I ever threw up my back. This kid when I was in fourth grade,
showed me how to do the figure four leg lock by putting me into it and was
fucking killing my knee. And I was trying to get up to, to get my free,
my leg from putting pressure on my kneecap.
And that's the first time I fucked up my lower back.
That a bad back since the lower,
since the a bad lower back since the a the fourth grade,
um,
chief Jay Strongbow would do the fucking rain dance.
That wasn't too fucking racist, wasn't once he did that,
he went into this crazy fucking,
he couldn't feel pain anymore and then he kicked the shit out of you. Uh,
all right. Enough of that shit.
So I was just looking at some of the old restaurants, um,
stuff that I used to watch, SD Jones, special delivery Jones.
The guy never fucking won. He was the most coolest fucking guy ever.
Um,
anyways, Mr Wonderful Roddy Roddy Piper.
I fucking love all those guys. So anyways, um, I was,
I never heard of this before, but yeah, it,
those of you who are fans of wrestling, if I,
there's this thing called the shoot match, which is basically, you know,
wrestling, it's sports entertainment. When I was a kid,
they used to argue that it was real. And then finally they said, now it's fake.
But, but what was great was once they said it was fake,
they could actually talk about all the real pain that they go through.
So I was kinda just watching some youtube videos about that and I came across
this stuff called a shoot match. So I was like,
what the hell is that shoot match in a shoot match is basically a wrestling
match where they're fake fighting and then somebody gets pissed at somebody else
and it becomes a real fight.
And what usually happens from the few that I saw is if the person's just not a
complete roid roided up psycho.
Um,
what it really is, is either somebody's not selling your moves,
like I'm fake punching you and you're just acting like it's not hurting.
So you making me look like an asshole or somebody you know you are,
you're allowing somebody to throw you and do a move and they bought it and fuck,
fuck you up and hurt you and then you get mad. Um,
I saw one with this guy.
This kid was new when he went to to execute some fucking throw and this guy was
just a psycho.
He didn't look like he landed that bad and he got up and just beat the fuck out
of this guy. Just threw him head first out of the ring.
The guy landed on his fucking head and we immediately had a concussion.
Then he picked the guy up and threw him into the metal stairs and this guy kept
selling. He, I guess he didn't have to sell the moves at that point,
but that one was fucking brutal. But the funniest one that you got to see,
and I'm having a link to it, it's the great Antonio Verse Antonio,
I hope I say it right so he doesn't come over and slap the shit out of me.
I knocky, I'm a Japanese guy,
so the Great Antonio is guy,
I can't even describe what he looks like.
He looks like a fucking troll with a page pageboy haircut and he's just
ridiculously fat and he's wearing the ugliest mustard colored yellow light
sweatpants with these military boots on.
I'm just not a good looking person.
And he's a wrestling this guy,
Antonio or knocky who's a Japanese guy who looks like a fucking movie star,
you know, he's got the old school movie star Chin,
he's got the Jack Lord Hawaii five o fucking haircut.
He's in great shape.
So they start fucking wrestling and wrassling and you know,
the Japanese guy is being a fucking professional and the Great Antonio who I
guess had a reputation for not selling people's moves and being selfish in the
ring.
You know the Japanese guy would punch him in his fat stomach and he wouldn't
even move.
And then the f the fat that would keep like punching his stomach like it's hard
as a rock and people were laughing in the crowd. The fucking guy,
like the Japanese guy throws him off the fucking ropes and the guy just sort of
stops, you know, and doesn't sell the fucking move.
And the Japanese guy's looking at him like, what the fuck?
And the crowd's laughing. You start seeing the Japanese to look in and I'm like,
dude, what the fuck? It's a long story short.
They get a few minutes into the round,
the Japanese guy has been selling everything to fat fucks doing the fat fucks
making the Japanese guy look like an idiot.
So fat fuck gets the Japanese guy against the ropes and he's punching almost
like the back of this guy's neck. Super fucking hard.
And the guy takes like three of them before he finally like blocks the fourth
one. And then he just snaps like, dude, what? Like fuck this.
And he just stands up and just open hands slaps this fat.
Fucking the head is hard as you possibly can
in the fat pageboy guy like turns his head, it's fucking phenomenal.
And the Japanese guy's going like, go making those like, come on,
let's fucking fight.
And the Fed fuck's still kinda like thinking he's just going to take one.
He slaps him in the fucking head again, then grabs his leg,
Japanese dude just snaps, fucking throws him on his belly,
boots them in the fucking head right now the ref is going like, whoa, whoa, hey,
whoa.
The fat fucks crawling around like a dog and a Japanese guy boots him in the
head again.
Now the fat guy is like fucking plank and he's laying down on the ground and the
Japanese guy boots him in the head like another fucking six times.
It's almost attempted murder. The fucking dude is a bloody mess.
They finally just call a match. And um,
it was one of the great pieces of justice I ever saw.
I didn't feel bad for the guy at all when he was getting boated in the head.
I was dying laughing. If you saw how hard this,
this fat fuck was punching this poor Japanese guy in the back of his neck and
he, the guy was taking it like a pro. And finally he was just like, what the f?
Cause it was all, he was like, he was hitting him for real. Um,
and he wasn't selling his moves. So you got, I'm going to, um,
have a link for it. If anybody else has some good ones up there. I,
it's just a whole new part of Youtube that, uh, you know, if you're at work,
if you're bored right now, just look it up yourself. Shoot matches.
S h o o t matches and uh,
there's just some legendary ones. And um, you know,
as much as they talked to wrestlers and stuff, like I, I never hear him,
you know, I always hear you know, about doing the road and these,
these great matches that they had. And then of course they talk about, you know,
you know, people getting the sickness, you know,
getting addicted to painkillers and drugs and all that shit.
They do all that type of shit. But, um,
nobody talks about all these fucking wrestling matches out there that, uh,
suddenly, um, that suddenly became real,
you know, so, um, I dunno. I hope you enjoy it. That's all I could say.
But anyways, let's get back to, uh, let's get back to the podcast.
So basically everything that I'm going to be talking about over the next couple
of months is going to be whatever I look out the window and see while we're
writing EFAs for family.
So anyways, um, yeah,
the day we're in the writer's room,
actually yesterday and all of a sudden we just hear like this fucking commotion,
right? And we look out our windows in this,
all these protestors just walking down the fucking taking up like a street,
you know, a lane of the street, like a, you know, like bike riders do now.
You know what I mean? When they ride down the street,
if there's two of them rather than riding single file,
they ride side by side because they want to talk and you know,
fuck the 50 cars that are behind them. Oh. And then by the way,
if they actually get hit, it's this major fucking tragedy. Like, oh my God can,
can you fucking believe that happened? Yes,
I can totally believe that happened completely.
A bicycle is simply a motorcycle without an engine.
That's what you're riding around on it,
but I know you're dressed up like you're in the Tour de France, you know,
you feel in a little European like that dude and breaking away,
maybe you speaking in Italian and you kind of forget that you're riding a
bicycle out in the street in Los Angeles home to arguably some of the worst
drivers on the planet. All right.
And I've always gotten off on technology and shit and saying, I don't like it.
Saying like we had enough technology somewhere around the early nineties we
should've stopped right about there. You let people die off.
Stop trying to cure fucking diseases.
Stop making a new technology that everybody has to go out and go buy this.
Just stop right fucking here. Okay. I mean,
I can remember the early nineties it was fucking great. It was fine.
Cars were fast enough, everything was fine.
He didn't have to go any further than that.
Wasn't it better when everybody wasn't on the fucking Internet?
I think it was even, I'm sitting here on the Internet right now.
I'd be willing to walk away from this shit. It's a great time.
Everything you did wasn't filmed. It wasn't fucking recorded.
There wasn't some satellite pointing at you're tracking you down the street as
you tried to get to a dairy queen.
But also the Illuminati can fucking take you out cause they probably own that
satellite, you know,
turn on some chip in your car and make it drive into a fucking tree, you know,
make white people. These are very mainstream stories here. Um, anyways,
um, these fucking prod,
they must've had a permit because it was a cop in front of them and behind them
and they're just walking down the street and I gotta tell you something.
All right, I'm all for the work and man, I'm all for that type of shit.
But the second you go out in the fucking street and you start blocking traffic,
I don't give a shit. If you're trying to say babies, I hate you and I want to,
I want to rent a cement truck and run you over. Like I was sitting in an office.
They weren't causing me any trouble.
And just the empathy that I had for the people trying to drive around them made
me want somebody to just fish tail into the fucking crowd.
So if you've ever been in a protest, let me ask you this question.
Is it
the objective to not only call attention to whatever it is you're complaining
about, but then don't you want people to
listen
and then be like, Oh wow, I didn't know that was going on.
You know,
so why would you annoy the shit out of everybody by like clogging up traffic?
To me, it's no different than fucking terrorists.
A lot of times whatever terrorists are bitching about, I'm like, yeah, I could.
I, I totally understand why you're upset about that,
but the then go and blow up a bunch of innocent people. I'm just like, yeah,
well that's not the way you solve it. Right.
My over simplifying this,
it's like we don't fly over there and drop bombs at ups.
Did that land on your baby? Yeah, we were trying to get the bad guy. Sorry,
your baby was within a 30 mile radius. I don't know. Um,
anyways, do you guys have or do you have, do you have like,
like I actually enjoy riding a bike, but, uh, I am an old school bike rider.
Like I ride up on the sidewalk. I don't wear a helmet. Um, you know,
I don't ride 90 miles an hour down the sidewalk and I don't care when people who
walk on the sidewalk give me a fucking dirty look.
It's just like I'm not going out there.
I'm not going out there and traffic,
cause I know everybody out there is like me and they're texting while they're
driving or they're fucking air drumming. You know,
God knows how many people are out there on prescription pills.
To go out there on a fucking motorcycle without an engine is really fucking
stupid. Yeah. And um,
I feel like this thing with like bike riders,
they have this thing where they feel like they're these victims and uh,
I find them way, way more hostile. Yeah.
Considering the position that they're in and they had this whole,
you will respect me and I have just as much as of right to be out here.
What should do you do? I mean, even though there is no bike lane,
they just painted,
painted a bicycle on the fucking street so they could get the federal grant.
That's the only reason why they do that shit. Right. And then a, you know,
all right, so you have a right to be out there,
but then you have to obey the rules of the road. And 99% of you don't.
When's the last time you saw a guy on a bicycle actually stop at a fucking red
light? They never do. They never do. They fucking look both ways.
They fucking glide right through the fucking thing. And then if they get hit,
then they frost the bicycle. Like, oh, well can you believe that happened?
What a poor baby. Um, I dunno.
I have to tell you, the people who ride bicycles out here and in Los Angeles,
the ride of their fucking minds and I am so anti those fucking cars that are
going to drive themselves, um,
until I go on the highways out here in Los Angeles. I'm just like,
you know what? I really think it should be. I think if you,
if you suck at driving, they should just take your right to drive away.
You can still have a car, but the car will drive for you because you suck at it.
You know what I mean? But I think if you're actually a decent driver,
you should then be allowed to continue driving.
So I think if you got rid of people who suck the driving right off the bat,
conservatively speaking, I'd say that's at least 30% of drivers,
you know? And then I think that middle, you know,
30 to 35% will just have the option because there's a lot of people that are
actually decent at driving. But if they're like, dude,
if I could just fucking take a nap and just sleep on the way to work for 45
minutes and just wake up when I'm there, I would rather do that.
So you figure it, at least half of them are gonna do it initially.
And then a half of those halfs are going to be like, well,
he has a self driving car. I, I, you know, grass is always greener.
I want one of those too.
And then I think you'll just basically get down to 18% of people that actually
truly enjoyed driving. And um, we'll get our own lane bulky.
This is my drink, we get our own lane, we get to drive as fast as we want.
And you guys are just all in robot cars, you know?
And then everybody who actually still continues to drive,
those are the people that, you know, when they're the first guy to make a left,
they get way out into the intersection.
They feel a sense of responsibility that two cars behind them will make it.
Those types of people, you know, those people that,
that realize the further left you go, the faster you go.
And if somebody on your bumper, you don't slam on the brakes, you get over,
that person's obviously in more of a here a hurry than you are.
You fucking let them go those, well, that's probably 18% of drivers.
What'd you say?
You like how I just painted myself as the fucking hero and all that? Oh yeah.
I'm one of the guys.
I'm one of the guys that knows how to do the things correctly. Um,
anyways, I hope this hasn't been too quiet. Let's plow ahead here.
Um, I am over. Oh, by the way, I'm over the whole fucking Tom Brady thing.
I actually have a buddy of mine that works in the A,
I can't say where he works, but just he basically broke it down and said,
listen, this is not a personal thing against the Patriots.
What it is is this is a corporation thing versus the employees.
And if the corporation says this is what's going to happen in the employee's
able to go around that,
then they get then that you got the nuts run in the nuthouse.
So basically Tom Brady was acquitted of any sort of cheating,
but the second trial, yes, he was. Look it up.
The second trial was, or very least, he was never convicted of that.
Um, this second trial was,
was more about does a corporation have a right to discipline its employees?
So you know what happened at Tom Brady outside in the real world,
in the United States of America, it wouldn't even have made it to trial.
All right? But with the lack of fucking evidence that yeah, they had,
okay, the on the other side, um,
you have within a corporation,
a corporation operates the way a corporation operates.
So they should be allowed to run their, but that's what it was about.
Are we as a corporation allowed to discipline our employees?
Are they able to go outside the corporation?
Are we gonna have to fucking deal with that?
And it was a big deal for the suits in the NFL to win that because if Tom Brady
wins that thing,
then every fucking suspension a player could simply take it outside of the NFL
and it really, um, whittles down the level of power that they have.
So I got to actually be honest with you,
I actually understand now I understand why the NFL did that.
And you know, if they've got to throw Tom Brady under the fucking bus,
then so be it. Now,
I know a lot of you guys out there think I'm skirting the fucking issue as far
as like, oh, he deflated. I'm not saying he didn't deflate the fucking ball,
but that's not why the colts lost by 35 fucking points.
I've said this is Zillion fucking times. You know,
Andrew Luck shouldn't even be on the colts that the colts actually tried the
season before he was available in the draft,
but they tanked the whole fucking season. And, um, I dunno,
just the amount of attention that Tom Brady gets versus, you know,
you know, have an HGH delivered to your fucking house in your wife's name.
And then you sit there in front of the Superbowl media for two weeks and it's
not even brought up.
And then you quote Forrest Gump in right off into the fucking sunset and then
everybody's cool with it. Um, whatever, that's all I want. Have,
what the fuck you gonna do. So anyways, plowing ahead here,
plowing ahead. Um, let me do, read a little bit of advertising here.
Then I'm going to get the fuck outta here and go stare at a computer screen.
All God Damn Day. I'm on it. Everybody. Joe Rogan's,
great company here. Uh, Alpha brain, instant from on. It is,
it is a delicious all natural stimulant free drink that helps support memory,
focus and processing speed.
The Boston Center for memory conducted a double blind study showing its
effectiveness. I don't know what a double blind study is but that sounds,
that sounds like all checks and balances Cleo.
So mad a buddy fucking itching up a storm.
I'm it's the secret weapon of pro athletes like a Bodie, Miller,
Brian Cushing and Jonathan Tabes.
But anyone can benefit from the effects of Alpha brain instant.
Simply mix a stick packet of Alpha brain instant into a water bottle and start
feeling the effects immediately.
It's non GMO gluten free,
stimulant free made of natural ingredients and most importantly it works.
And as a special offer to my listeners, special offer,
my listeners can try Alpha brain institute for free by going to on it.com/bill o
n n I t.com/bill to get free samples of Alpha brain instant.
Now. Oh look who's back club. Debbie cut up. Gabby,
we've been there for you. We've been there.
You come home after a long exhausting day at work and all you want to do is sip
a glass of wine and relax.
Get a little buzz going and forget about your miserable life.
But unless you plan ahead, you probably don't even have a bottle in your house.
And getting up and going to the store is not happening cause you're wiped out.
Please include all of the following points. Why wouldn't I club Debbie?
Can she stop to tear? Um,
you can finally relax because you'll never have to worry about being wine free
again. Club Debbie connect for one again.
I like Parker brothers is a revolutionary new wine club that sends you wine
directly to your doors. Saving all those trips to the grocery store.
Not only just clip Debbie it catch you four o'clock, four cross.
Why am I talking about connect four?
I just pictured that's what he does in his retirement.
He plays Parker Brother Games, shoots and ladders connect for monopoly.
Um, sends you wine, they send you wine that you will love. Drinking Club W's.
Easy. Six question quiz figures out your pallets.
So every bottle you receive is perfectly tailored to your taste club. Debbie,
I love playing the Banjo,
works directly with vineyards to cut out the middleman, which saves you money.
Clip Debbie full from my brother champion. You know, he's out of it,
even offers a no risk guarantee that you'll love. Um, and you'll love, oh,
you'll guarantee that you'll love what they send you right now.
Club W is offering my listeners 20 $20 off your first order when you go to club
debby.com/burr and it gets even better. I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So club w will actually pay for shipping on orders of four,
four bottles or more. So take something off your to do list. Just go to club w.
Dot com slash bird and get $20 off your first order.
Now that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr. All right,
couple more here and I just scroll down. Oh,
zip recruiter. Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect car,
you need to post your job on all the top job sites and now you can with Zip,
but trudeau.com you can post your jobs to a hundred plus job sites including
social media, including networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click. Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just once.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface. No juggling emails or calls in your office.
Quickly scan candidates, rate them, and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by over 800,000 businesses and
right now listeners can try zip,
but for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ZipRecruiter
slash.com/burr one more time. Hey, zip recruiter.com/berm all right,
what do I got left here? How many? How many? All right,
I read these last two later, so I'll tell you, I'll read them later. You know,
um, oh, congratulations to the meet me in St Louis.
Louis meet me at the fair St Louis Blues, got the job done.
Um, what a fucking huge one for that city. Um,
that's always great to see that,
but it was instantly also depressing not to see Chicago when it, because uh,
then he, you don't get to watch, you know, all the great players that they have,
tapes, Kane, Dunkin, Keith and all those guys. Um,
it's weird to see the Blackhawks and the kings out in the first round and look
who's coming up the outside and they come San Jose sharks,
the fucking, I mean,
their logo should literally be somebody choking on a piece of fucking steak.
You know, I don't know why steak,
but just choking on something that I don't think you could find a team that's
won more hockey games and left in the first round or just not want a cup.
And I don't know what it is about the San Jose sharks.
I just don't have any sympathy for them or their fucking fans. I don't know why.
I think it has to do with that teal color that they have.
You know, maybe it's because the kings got rid of their, their fucking,
you know, royal colors, the Laker colors that they had.
And they took basically black, white and gray because you know,
you think the sharks would have like a gray looking uniform.
You'd think if you had, like, if he came up with a killer name, like the sharks,
like that animal, that fish there was just sitting there on the table.
Cause you know, you know the deal with sports teams, this,
there's only so many ferocious fucking animals to pick from, you know,
and then once that goes out the window,
then you kinda gotta talk about like the jobs people do,
like a where the packers, yeah.
Everybody pack stuff up here and where the fucking these guys or those guys,
you know, and then when you're really out of names,
that's when you start naming teams after like weather, right? The hurricanes,
the heat, the thunder, right.
The mystique or whatever the fuck you come, flurries the Florida flurries.
That would make sense. That doesn't snow down there. Um,
Florida Sun showers, it's just really going to be bad.
That's why you can't go beyond 30 teams and he's fucking leak, you know, or 32,
I guess that's where up to, but shocks was just sitting there.
We'd just sit there on the table and I remember thinking like, Oh wow,
the shocks, that's a great name. I can't wait to see that uniform.
And it was like bump, bump, a bomb bow.
It's a shark and he's biting a hockey stick and half. Well yeah,
then you're going to get a penalty for, for slashing and today's NHL,
right second. The stick breaks automatically. I'm, I'm sorry. I don't know.
I don't know what it is. I just don't, uh,
this is where I have sympathy for the shock fans.
I know what it's like to root for a fucking team year in and year out and they
fucking blow it. I don't know what it's like for the last 15 years.
All of a sudden my hell turned into a fucking paradise cause everybody started
fucking winning. But before then, you know,
I was a red sox fan living in New York City with all that curse of the Babe Shit
going on, you know, Boston sports, we're in the fucking shitter.
Basically when I was growing up,
we had the Boston Celtics and then up to 86 and then once led by his died.
Um, and then Reggie Lewis died. I mean the whole thing, it just, it just,
the wheels fell off for like 20 fucking years. But, um,
fortunately nowadays you can go out and buy a championship,
which we did in 2007. Um, anyways,
so I'm just trying to say congratulations to St Louis.
Now my two favorite teams out west,
the stars and the blues are playing each other. And um,
I think I'm gonna stick with the blues just cause, uh, I don't know.
I just worked St Louis, I saw how excited they were. And you know,
I like the stars cause I used to like the Minnesota north stars and I like the
people on the stars, but I'm not into their fans either.
You Know Dallas fans at the end of the fucking day,
you don't give a fuck about the stars.
There's only one star in Dallas and that's the one in this side of the cowboys
helmet. You know it's fucking true. You know,
that's all you give a fuck about.
Those beautiful ladies coming out and their Little Horry Cherries,
Charlie's angel outfits. That's what you give a fuck about that.
You give a fuck about that.
And your shiny four-door pickup truck that's never seen dirt. Right.
Come in there with your fake tid fucking botox,
Dolly Parton fucking hair check going down the street looking like a couple of
televangelists. That's what you do out there in Dallas in the big day.
Isn't that what you do? I don't. I'm just fucking with you.
I'm the one great thing though. I do like, you know something.
I can't say I'm totally anti-technology because uh, I do love Tivo,
but back in the day I also had a VCR so I could have take games, right? I'm,
I'm saying like the one thing,
the citing thing that I have in the writers room as we're doing all the work,
no, is, is the excitement is right around five o'clock.
I know we only got a couple hours left and that whatever game I want to watch is
currently being taping and it being taped. And I don't go on Twitter.
I don't look at my phone or anything that I just shut it off and uh,
I'm able to come home and watch all these fucking great series and uh,
there's just the best, you know, I actually retweeted, there was civic duty.
You guys see that thing on Twitter ad? That dude becoming a hockey fan
is fucking black dude was hilarious. Like he goes, you know what,
I'm going to give this hockey shit at tri and he just starts live tweeting game
seven of the blues. And uh, the Blackhawks,
I guess he decided to root for the blues.
He was just tweeting this hilarious shit. Like what the fuck is a power play?
I don't know who this cane guy is,
but we gotta stop this motherfucker and that towards the end of the game he
goes, what's so like the goalie just leaves?
Then the best question he ever, as I've ever heard a hockey goes for real.
Why don't, why does it, the whole other team just stand in front of their net.
You know when you're up by one in the just shooting, like why don't you do that?
That's fucking hilarious. Um,
that's just someone who's never gotten hit in the foot with the fucking puck.
It's like you really, I, and whenever I watched somebody block a shot,
like I just, the fucking balls that that takes you do that and pick up hockey,
you're going to be limping for the rest of the fucking week to watch these guys
block an NHL shot. They're out of their minds. But, um, anyways,
I'm up to 30 minutes here. I gotta kind of cut this thing short.
I know I usually do a little bit more time than this, but I gotta I gotta go,
I gotta go to work or Billy goes to work every day,
eat a fucking salad every day at lunch. That's what I do.
They like a big fucking pussy every fucking day. Um,
and I'm actually doing okay. And I tried to lose two pounds this week,
which I think I did, but I had a Burrito last night,
so I only lost like a fucking pound.
So next week I have to be down to one 76 going to buckle down over this weekend
and fucking workout and um, get myself back down to about a buck 70.
Um, by the way, I think the Celtics are playing tonight.
I think game six, that's obviously a must went well winning at home,
but we're getting pounded. We got fucking pounded that last game.
Second joke was almost, we almost losing by fucking 30, but you know,
we're a young team. We'll see hopefully next year with all our draft picks.
Maybe we'll get Kevin Duran or that unit brow guy from fucking New Orleans.
Although I don't think either one of those are good. You know,
as far as for the league,
I think Doran should stay in Oklahoma and I think unibrow guy should stay in New
Orleans. Does that make sense?
My out of my fucking mind to think that that if you come in with the team,
you ought to fucking,
unless they're fucking you over like shack should have stayed with the magic.
You know, Shit. It came out just piled on with the fucking Lakers.
Look what happened.
He went a couple championships and then he threw out his next celebrating as he
went down. The Courtney was never the same. All right.
Let me do a couple more reads here and then I gotta get Outta here. All right,
hallux. He likes h. E. L. I. X.
What is it about buying a mattress that leaves you feeling violated? Well,
I don't know. What the fuck happen to you at this store? Jesus Christ violated.
That's a really strong word. Especially when you have a mattress.
I was phased out. I heard him on Pucko his pants.
Um, is it, is it the pushy salespeople,
the fake president day sales or the fact that you know you'll regret what you
bought as you do the walk of shame out of the mattress store?
These days are over.
Thanks to helic sleep where you can buy a mattress online customized for you for
hundreds of dollars instead of thousands,
go to Helen's dot com he looks whatever,
answer a few simple questions and he looks,
creates your custom sleep profile to build you the perfect mattress.
The results, our customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep. All right,
you want to fill in the other 70%. Don't drink, don't drink any boosts.
You'll sleep like a baby.
Your mattress will arrive at your door in about a week and shipping is 100%
free. You have 100 nights to try it out. And if you don't love it,
they'll pick you up for free and give you 100% refund, no questions asked.
It's like it never happened. If you do love your new health mattress,
keep it and your dignity a.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep. Go to Helen's sleep.com/bar and get $50 off your order.
That's helix, sleep.com/bar hey, heloc
sleep.com/berg all right. I said it both ways throughout the whole thing.
All right. Tracker fucking tracker, tracker,
smartphones, Matt Katz, Matt Holmes.
Technology has made everything smart but losing his stuff's still makes people
feel really stupid.
Tracker makes losing things a thing of the past tracker is a called tracker.
I they haven't said it enough here.
Tracker is a coin size device that locates misplaced keys, wallets, bags,
computers, anything in seconds. Just pair of tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find his precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. Why don't I have one of these fucking things?
I lose my phone all the time. Lose your phone. There you go.
Press the button on tracker and your phone rings.
Even when it's on silent with over 1.5 million devices tracker as the largest
crowd gps network in the world. So your lost items shows up on a map,
even if it's miles away, never lose anything.
Again with tracker listeners to this show,
get a special discount 30% off your entire order. Go to the spelled t,
h e t r a C K e r.com and enter Promo code bird.
The hardest thing you'll ever have to do is find their website.
Go to the tracker.com go to the tracker.com right now and enter Promo Code Bar
for 30% off your entire order. That's the highest I've ever heard of anything.
Again, that is the tracker.com Promo Code Burn.
It's like the Ohio State University, um,
which at the end of the day is just a state school,
so they should get over themselves. All right,
that's the podcast for this Thursday. Have a wonderful weekend. Your con,
if a you're protesting and you want my support, stay up on [inaudible]
the sidewalk. If you're riding a bicycle,
please be careful and ride single file.
And have some fucking courtesy for the people behind you.
And if there's a red light, why don't you fucking stop at the thing. Okay.
And stop wearing aerodynamics. Shit. All right.
It doesn't make you any faster and you, there's nothing at stake. All right. Ah,
alright. Enjoy the music and the, uh, the highlights from podcasts from it,
from years gone by.
Okay.
[inaudible] seize
the day.
[inaudible]
hey, what's going on? [inaudible] the Monday morning podcast
that I'm doing at seven 30 at night Pacific coast time.
So it's still 10 30 on east coast. So it's still Monday. Uh,
what's going on with me? I'm cooking fish. That's what I'm doing right now.
Cooking fish.
And I'm steaming some Broccoli cause I have to be in shape next week.
Why you ask? Because on November 10th,
I'm taping my one hour comedy special,
uh, for a DVD. I like that segue right out of the fish and Broccoli,
right into the goddamn comedy. Jesus Christ. I'm a professional.
Um, and this is the deal, man. I just, if you guys want to go,
the tickets are free. Yes, they are free.
All right. And, uh, I sent out a bulletin and a,
one of the problems I'm having is, um, all you have to do,
you just go to Belper at Broadway video and just write bill burrs and capitals,
Bill Burr, Broadway video. Just request your tickets,
leave your name and your phone number. It's all in the bulletin. But you know,
people don't like to read.
So what they're doing is they're reading the first quarter of it and then
they're sending me the email with their name,
with their requests and their phone numbers. So being a comedian,
I'm going to have to call them and say some stupid shit.
Now I don't have those 10 minutes on my phone. The fuck am I kidding?
I think I have the worst plan ever.
I probably made like seven phone calls last month and I've got a $380 cell phone
bill
screamed like a bitch echoed in my fucking living room. Um,
yeah. So that's the deal. So, uh,
anybody in the New York City area that wants to come out or I don't know if
you're going to be in New York and you want to come down. Um,
I'm taping my special and I,
I obviously don't want to take my special in front of 40 people. Uh,
it's a nice big theater, nice and cushy and um,
I want to make you laugh so seriously. Go to bill bar at Broadway,
video.com to get your tickets.
And uh, with that, I think I'm done. Um,
I think I'm done whoring out my stuff. Is that it?
I Dunno. It's like I got one other thing here. God Damn it.
I'm never organized for these things. Really not. Um,
I see these available on uh,
God listen to the little walls right now and she's fucking brutal. Oh,
here we go. Yeah. People who want to get the extra,
the extra of the bonus material on my CV.
Just go to a what our records.com.
I want to say backslash, I can't speak this computer shit.
What I reckon stop Com backslash backslash disc God discography to scrub the
fuck you said de disco and then Graffy. How about that?
D I s D I s c o g r a p h y.
Dot. Html.
Is anybody out there scrolling that down?
Like fucking radon radar Riley right now? Um, all right.
Yeah, so that's the deal. So I got my DVD taping is on December,
November 10th November 10th this is the,
I am the worst at this shit. I'm the worst at this shit. If you know what,
just go on my page. If you click down,
what it's going to do is it's going to take you to my website.
It's going to take you on a little journey to a place I call bill bird.com and
you just click on upcoming shows and then just click on November 17th and then
you don't have to listen to me anymore. In fact,
just hit stop and just do that right now and there won't be any more confusion.
Just read the whole email though and bill bar at Broadway video.
All right there. I said at 98 times.
Then I just make my fucking Broccoli all soggy.
I did who steams Broccoli and does a podcast, you know, who does I do.
I do you think Rodney Dangerfield of it? Did some shit like that.
I mean probably did some blow, but it was the eighties okay.
I would have been on bluff. It was the 80s now I'm just on crystal meth.
All right. Hey and Oh, last,
last time I did a podcast also people said, you know, 50 things.
I just sort of meander. You know, I cook, I cook fish. I uh,
I seen shit. I drive my car and you know,
I got into people I'm running out of stuff to talk about. You know,
I really thought that my life was interesting enough that once a week I could
babble about it for 10 minutes.
And you know what I realized nobody's that interesting.
Nobody is that fucking interesting. You know,
like how I did that rather than just taking it myself and just say,
you know what? I'm really not that interesting. A guy.
I dragged everybody down with me, including you listen to this.
I haven't said that you are not that interesting. You realize that. What a Dick.
Right. All right, so people sent me some questions.
I'm going to try to answer these things as honestly as I can so you can get to
know me a little better. Alright, what did, what did this guy, right?
This Guy Brad. The fuck names a kid, Brad. You know what I mean?
That's like, you don't even give a shit. It's not, you know,
it's like you don't want to be popular.
You don't want him to get the shit kicked out of him. You just,
he was just like, you know, do you want fries? Yeah. Yeah. I'll get fries.
What do you want? What do you want to call her kid? Hey Brad. Yeah, Brad is,
Brad wants to know, do you ever feel like you have time off?
Wait a second. I can't read out loud that why?
Do you ever feel like you have time off or does everyone you meet expect you to
make them laugh on call Brad?
You know what, that fucking sentence goes in three different directions.
It's like when a plane is doing it as pattern because there's too many goddamn
people in the world and they don't want to go into a holding pattern.
That's what your fucking, you just did the DVD.
I don't know the sentence version of my fucking flight into Newark.
Do you ever feel like you have time off?
I think it's going to be about going on vacation or does everyone you meet
expect you to make them laugh on call? You mean on
Cue Bread? But I got a question for you.
Where the fuck did you go to school and learn how to communicate?
Thought two sentences. Is that a run on it? No, it isn't. I don't think it is.
Do you ever feel like you have time off or does everyone you meet expect you to
make them laugh on call on call?
Like what am a nurse you asking me if I do like a like benefits for sick people?
Yeah, I do. I do those. I know what he's saying. Do you have,
do you ever feel like you can just relax and not be a Zany douchebag? Yeah.
Offstage? Uh, yeah, I, I don't,
I don't walk around with a lampshade on my head if that's what you're asking me.
Um, I actually know what I do find.
I find people try to make me laugh and they come up to me and they tell me
horrific jokes and then when they're done with them,
if I can even guess when they're done.
That's the worst part is when somebody tells you a joke and it's so bad,
you still think they're in the middle of it.
So you're still sitting there with your eyebrows up. You know, when you do that,
when you're, when you're, you're trying, like when you know somebody sucks,
whatever they're doing sucks,
but you don't have the balls to just stare at them.
Like your story sucks but you can't fake like, it's interesting.
So the only way to do it, you just put your eyebrows up like, Huh? Yeah. Uh Huh.
And then he's just staring at you and it's over and you're sitting there with
your eyebrows up by your fucking hairline and you realize that your moment to
laugh was a, it has come and gone. That's what I have had people tell me.
They tell me awful,
awful jokes and then they tell me about some guy they work with and B and
they're like, oh my God, you, you got to put this in your act.
I worked with this Guy Mac, right?
And every day he eats chicken salad and then pictures,
picture fucking 20 minutes of that
as you're standing in an airport trying to hear when they're boarding zone
seven, however the fuck they work it out. That's what ends up happening.
So no, I don't feel like I have to be on offstage.
I just try to chill out and uh,
I certainly don't do it around my family because anytime they even remotely fit
funny around my family, they break my balls. They don't even laugh.
They just go, Oh really? Let's go bill. You're going to put that in your act.
It count. Um, okay. That was question number one.
And I guess that's how I'm going to do them.
I'm gonna make fun of how people ask me questions.
I'm going to shit on their lives because I'm not happy with my own on some
fucked up level. Oh fuck. Seven 55 I only to fish.
What kind of fish? And I think it's called Talia, I don't know.
Get some lemon zest on it or some, I don't know what the fuck it is.
I'm eating like a, an Asian and a communist country.
People are in great goddamn shape. And last time you saw a fat Asian, honestly,
the only time you get to see a fat Asian,
they hanging out with other white people and they're walking out of McDonald's.
So if anybody Asian is listening, stop hanging out with us because uh, you know,
nine out of 10 of us are going to a fucking cuckoo room. Um,
all right. Uh, okay. This brings me to my question. Here's this guy.
What is this?
What is your worst slash funniest experience in dealing with the comedy club
owner? Also?
Have you ever broken the news to a comedian that he just isn't that funny,
if not, how often you want to? That's a great question.
Um, as far as the club owners, the worst and funniest experiences, too many,
too many of them. Uh,
the most recently is I worked for this psycho up in Seattle who, uh,
he brings me into town. He's going to pay me a disgusting amount of money,
right?
So I need to sell tickets and this guy doesn't advertise the show at all,
so I don't sell any tickets.
So then he yells at my management company, you know, I mean,
w even if you had Jesus Christ playing at your club,
you, you know, you,
you couldn't just put his name out on the marquee and have somebody would,
you know,
you'd at least have to have somebody with the fucking sandwich board walking up
and down the street to let you know that the son of God is down the street.
Jesus Christ would have a difficult time selling out a club without advertising.
He'd have to be doing miracles on the corner,
like one of those fucking dated blame guys hanging upside down in a cube of ice
or some shit trying to get people to come down there. Okay,
that's the son of God. That's what he would have to do. Okay,
now you're talking about little old me. Right? But thank God this guy,
Marty reamer up there put me on the radio and then we sold a bunch of tickets
and then the guy, you know,
he does like a one 80 and all of a sudden he loves me and he's one of these
guys. He's such a psycho. I don't even care if he fucking,
here's this because he's a psycho and psychos have, they don't,
they don't remember anything. He'll be mad, you know,
throw a stapler at his assistant that he's underpaying and then he'll come to
like when David banner comes back from being the hall can,
you won't even remember that I said this shit. All right.
So if you are listening all that shit you said to my management company got back
to me. Okay. Fucking fucking psycho.
Get to psycho. You get a comb over to God. Those are the worst.
Who Do you think you're fooling? Um, all right.
Oh, the only one. Have you ever broken the news to a comedian that he just,
isn't that funny? If not, how often do you want to, I'll tell you right now,
I would never do that to somebody. I would never do that to somebody.
I, uh, I don't think somebody is funny. I just a,
I keep it to myself because there's been a lot of people who really sucked for a
long time and then all of a sudden they figure out how to be funny. And,
uh, I dunno. I look at everybody like they like me. When I started out,
I didn't, when I started out, I had no confidence and uh,
you know, I if one person,
if some established comedian came up to me and said that they didn't wait a
minute, somebody did that, somebody did come up to me.
That's right. It is Vietnam comedy flashback.
I was working in the comedy connection in Boston,
Massachusetts is how long ago it was, I had a big Red Afro.
I was wearing a striped shirt with a vest.
Remember in the mid nineties he's right as grunge was starting to die,
but it was before in sync and the boy band thing,
it's sorta ray of red around like the sublime era
and that people like for half a second we're women's vests.
It's just one of those things.
It's like when black people try to make a pink that color,
remember they was like thugs were wearing painful like a week and a half.
I remember seeing that thinking if black people pull this off, that that's it.
That's the game set match. There was nothing that they cannot make cool.
And that shit went away real quick while the white version of that was best.
Okay. I know a lot of people fucking laughing at you,
but if there's other people my age out, they are late 30 [inaudible] to 40.
You remember it, you had it on and uh, you know,
it's right after doc Martins. It was the bridge, the vests. All right,
get to the fucking point of the story. Jesus Christ. All right. So anyways,
so that's what I'm wearing.
I go onstage and I kill and I get off stage.
And then this other comedian comes up and he's like,
he's a redhead too, but he's like 60 years old.
He's basically me in 40 years at the time when he came up to me and uh,
and he just came up to me and he just like, you know, you know what I mean?
You need to set up there then it was all bullshit. You know, you just have to,
you're jumping around and blah, blah, blah. Any just shit all over my act.
You know,
you ever watch the discovery channel with some sort of fucking Willdabeast
trying to market territory. That's what he did to my act. And uh,
everything he was saying was like a punch through my chest,
pass my heart and into my soul. And uh,
it was fucking brutal. And I still had a day job,
so I had to go back to work for like three days before my next show.
And all I'm hearing in my head is this guy's voice telling me that I suck.
And like back then I had such little confidence,
I just took what anybody said to me as law. So if they said I sucked,
then I sucked. I didn't have the brains to be like, well,
it's just an old bitter comic. He used to be a young red head and now you know,
is not so young anymore. And uh, you know,
he's a little drunk and he's being a Douche. This has nothing to do with me.
I didn't know how to do that back then. I was like, oh my God,
somebody with TV credits thinks I suck,
so therefore I must suck. So whatever fast forward.
And that's why I'd never do it to somebody. I would never do that.
I would want to make somebody feel like that. Now if you heckle me, you know,
all bets are off. I don't give a shit.
I wants to make you a just short of suicidal.
I'm sure that's Kinda childish. But, uh, that's it.
So to answer your question now, I don't say that and uh,
I gotta be honest with you. I hate watching people bond unless it's my friends.
If it's a friend of mine and who's funny and I watched him go up there and try a
new joke,
especially if it's a high energy joke and they end with this big Ted dye look on
their face and they get nothing.
I can tell you that nothing makes a comedian civilian version of that is
watching a good friend dios fall down a flight of stairs.
I mean it's just fucking hilarious.
No matter even if they dislocate their shoulder or whatever, you know,
at some point as you're driving them to the hospital,
you're going to have to turn and look out the driver's side window and you got
to kind of laugh. You know this, you know, you do it subtly cause you like him.
He's your friends, right? Jesus Christ.
Cause I take longer to answer a fucking question. Was trying to get quicker.
Uh, where do we go here? What do we got next? What do we get next?
I'll answer a couple more of these. All right. Um,
what's your most embarrassing moment on stage or in life? Jesus Christ.
I don't know. I block them out at this point.
Had somebody throw a dinner roll at me. Does that count?
That dental floss thrown at me? If you look on my website, I get fucking,
somebody threw a doughnut at me. I mean, I don't know.
Somebody stole an ice had me a I, you know, I probably,
the first time I bombed in front of an all black crowd,
maybe that was the fucking, that was the worst vomit in front of a white crowd.
Sucks enough. But like you just feel like you suck.
But when you bomb and you're the only white guy in the room when you bomb and
you really feel like you're bombing for the entire white race and you're also
reinforcing the stereotype that white people aren't funny.
And it was just the worst. And I was standing up there first joke bombed.
I ran to the second joke, the next joke bombed.
At this point I have like dry mouth,
like I can't even explain it. Just, you know, when like concrete,
I don't know when it gets so dry you can,
you can break it off and it seems that, you know that little powdered mis.
Just imagine if you just took a whole handful of that and stuck it in your
mouth.
That's how dry my mouth was and for some reason no one was heckling.
They would just sort of sitting there just looking around is that the show
hadn't even started, which had had been,
it'd been going great for like an hour and I went into my third joke in total
panic mode, trapped in my act, just mobile on Blah Blah,
blah,
blabbing on and then all of a sudden in the back is big black girl is,
she don't want those voices. She didn't, she wasn't even saying it loud,
but it was just the hot summer day and it just carried throughout the club.
As I'm up there babbling on in dead silence,
I just tear her clear as day. Just go.
I ain't last yet. And the whole place just started laughing.
It was like a whole nother show was going on while I was still up there in my
act and I was so green.
I didn't know what to do when I should have done was addresses, but I didn't.
I continued doing my act, which made them laugh at me even more. It was,
it was absolutely humiliating, but I got to admit,
I didn't really think about it until you ask me that fucking question.
So either I'm over it or I'm just a complete denial.
Okay. Why are you still single? Uh,
cause I'm a psycho and if you don't know that,
listen to my podcast, listen to this one. Right? Fine.
I keep forgetting to take the god damn fish up. Um, anyways. All right.
I think it's time for me to eat like an Asian in a communist country.
I tell him, if you want to get shredded, man, that's what I'm telling you, man.
You don't want to fucking fuck all these stupid other diets. What are they? That
the South Beach, Manhattan beach, it's always like a beach, right?
All that bullshit. You don't need to do that. That's what you do.
You eat like somebody in Asia just squatting down on the side of the road and
some zen like no, those Buddhist monks, you know, you ever seen a fat monkey?
You just don't see it. A Buddhist monk. Okay.
But you got those friar tuck white ones. They're fat man. It's just,
I don't know what it is. It sits.
We got that double cheeseburger thing going on, you know, but, uh,
I don't know. I, you know what,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about this point. All right,
so I'm going to wrap this up. Uh,
I want to thank everybody who listened to and called into the uninformed show.
Uh, the, the radio show I do with Joe to Rosa and uh, that's quickly to come.
And one of the most fun things that I do here. And, uh,
in the entertainment world, we did our Halloween show. And real quick,
so we had on a, uh,
a real live witch and a couple of people from the Church of Satan,
cause we wanted to learn about that shit. And I get, it was unbelievable.
They were the most boring fucking people I've ever seen.
People in the Church of Satan evidently don't believe in the devil there.
They just don't like, Nah,
the Church of Satan is just giving into the desires you want to be and do.
And Yeah. You know, I stop at Red Lights and a,
I yield to pedestrians. It was the most excruciating hour of radio.
I think I've ever done flats. But we did have the drum battle.
Me and Joe de Rosa go to uninformed radio.com.
Later on this week we have the, uh,
the video up Joe one the plane through the song part and I won the freestyle so
you can vote and see which one of us is better. You know, it's,
I know it's kind of fucking gay, but we had a good time. Um, so that's it.
I'm going to be in Las Vegas on November 17th doing Ed sees as palace.
Jeez, it's so beautiful in here, isn't it? I wish I had a toga.
Fuck it. Hey Casinos, they have the ugliest goddamn rugs. I mean,
this what they must pay per square footage for a casino rug. It's just fucking,
it's mind boggling how ugly it is. You know?
Got the Vidya drink it.
Why didn't I buy those myths to help you take a hot plate out and you guys won't
listen to me to take a hot plate out with a couple of districts.
Maybe I could burn myself in the fucking podcast and see if this thing is don't
fuck out.
This shit done. You know what the worst thing about cooking a white fish?
You have no fucking idea when it's done. All right.
You know what?
I think I'm really trashing white people on this made fun of Asians a little
bit. I'm talking about how fucking fat white people are and uh,
wait a second. Is that done? Oh Shit. That's gone. Look at that. Oh,
would you look at that? If I was emerald right now, Emeril Lagasse,
I would fucking,
I would take some chocolate chips and throw them on top and go Bam and start
screaming just to get the crowd going. I fucking hate that show. All right.
If you want to watch Emma Lugosi,
you watched the essence of the animal because then he's just sitting there
cooking. If you watch Emeril live or whatever his show is to do,
he, he's like, he's got to entertain people. Once you have a studio audience,
do you ever notice that? Then all of a sudden you just got to dumb it down.
You can't cook anymore. Now you gotta be like, I got some shirts.
Everybody starts applauding. Like they can't afford it. They know it's sugar.
Okay? You get it for free at a diner, right? You're not kicking it up a notch.
You making people or,
and you contributing to the diabetes and this goddamn country. All right Emma.
So why don't you fucking take it down a few notches. And uh,
what about the musicians? He actually has musicians on that show. Jesus Christ.
And you know, when you start out to be a musician, you think, you know, I dunno,
you're gonna fucking play arenas. Well, if you're going to do the TV thing,
maybe you'll be in the Conan band or the tonight show band.
You really don't think you're going to be
playing your flute while, you know,
in between some guy teaching somebody how to make Lasagna.
Why did you make me feel better about myself and my career? Anyways, that's it.
Go to bill [inaudible] at Broadway, video.com for the tickets. Uh,
please come out to the show. I've got a lot of new stuff.
I haven't been in New York for minutes and uh, come on down.
Seven 45 November 10th. Come down an hour early.
I will make you laugh. That is what I do. So that's it guys. All right,
keep the questions, comment. Oh wait a minute.
Congratulations to the Boston red sox. We wanted again.
And uh,
I want to apologize to every other team in the league that isn't the red sox or
the Yankees, cause that's all that ESPN seems to talk about. I mean,
it's ridiculous. I mean,
we won it last night and I just sit through 20 minutes of shit of what that
means to the Goddamn Yankees. Who gives a fuck?
What does it mean to the Indians? What does it mean to the angels?
What does it mean to fucking other people out? They don't count.
They don't count. You know, that's how ESPN treats the rest of the league.
They treat the red sox and the Yankees like they're,
they're real kids and they street treat everybody else like stepchildren.
It's like you ever see that family that adopted those kids and they kept the
check and they didn't feed the kids and they said they're regular kids.
You know, if ESPN adopted children, that that's what they do.
Doesn't even fucking make sense. My Broccoli's all soggy.
Is there anything worse than that? Now, when you do that,
what you've done is you boiled all the new nutrients out of it.
So what I'm doing here is I'm just eating clean, soggy shit. Oh,
that's disgusting. The fish is great though. Fish is great. All right.
There's a lesson for you. Never Seen Broccoli when you're doing a podcast.
All right. Come on down to my taping. If you can't make that come out to Vegas,
you can't make that. I'll probably end up in your area.
Please send me more questions.
Thank you everybody for listening and giving a shit about me.
What I do means a lot to me. Have a great week. Alright guys. Thank you.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].